I've said before that the issue of the
minimum wage is a complicated issue
I've been asked before would a $15
minimum wage nationally be good or bad
for the economy and the truth is that a
lot of the answer depends on where you
are measuring whether it's good or bad
for the economy and I've said this
before um you know we could stick the
talking points on this show and do black
and white stuff like everything is
either very good or very bad it's all
good or all bad that's not the reality
okay so when we think about a $15
minimum wage in lower cost of living
places where a $15 minimum wage might be
doubling the prevailing minimum wage
there could be negative effects in some
ways in terms of the destabilizing
effect that that could have on the local
job market etc that's a reality on the
other hand in high cost of living places
a $15 minimum wage may not even be
enough number one and number two is
unlikely to hurt the economy relative to
how much it will help people afford
their day to day lives and inject more
money into the wallets of workers so
we've got to be thoughtful here there
are some who say raising the minimum
wage has no negative impact period
that's not true I mean that's just not
true in all cases of course there are
people on the other side who say any
increase to the minimum wage causes
layoffs
it causes business closures it will blow
up the cost of everything because
businesses will just raise prices in
order to account for that but of course
that also isn't true today we have a new
case study from new york city new york
city raised the minimum wage to $15 an
hour a year ago the restaurant industry
which is one of the ones that is often
the focus of minimum wage increases the
restaurant industry is doing really well
in new york city
despite this new york city restaurants
have seen increased revenue and they've
also seen increased employment now the
way they've done it is that prices have
gone up slightly at New York City
restaurants detractors of the minimum
wage
will immediately say whoa whoa whoa you
raise prices customers will stop going
out to eat the businesses will fail
they'll have to fire everybody and the
minimum wage increase will backfire
hasn't happened and you know why prices
don't have to go up very much imagine
that the minimum wage goes up for
example 8% and imagine that restaurants
account for that by increasing food
prices by 8% now more than likely they
wouldn't because the labor costs are
only part of what it costs to run a
restaurant so an 8% increase in wages
would not even require an 8% increase in
prices but ok imagine that wages go up
8% food prices go up 8% a $10 burger
becomes 10 dollars and 80 cents now I'm
not gonna write that off as nothing but
for most people you're not going to go
out to eat a different number of times
because the burger goes from 10 dollars
to 10 dollars and 80 cents this is the
reality I don't want to be insensitive I
don't I'm not ignoring that 80 cents on
a 10 dollar meal can be meaningful to
many people but the reality is that for
the most part you're not going to
drastically change your habits if your
burger goes from 10 dollars to 10
dollars and 80 cents but on the other
side of the ledger everybody who works
at the restaurant and gets a raise
because of that minimum wage increase
now has more money to go out to other
restaurants and to patronize other
businesses where they live that is
hugely stimulative to the economy
overall now there's no question that if
the New York City economy starts to fail
because it's been a strong economy in
New York City for the last year if the
New York City economy starts to fail it
will be bad for lots of people it'll be
bad for restaurants it'll be bad for
their workers but in the economic
environment in New York City of the last
year the minimum wage increase has been
a very very positive thing now there are
also trickle up effects to having better
paid workers other than just they have
money to spend at local businesses they
are happier they have a higher standard
of living
thus our providing better service which
is good for the businesses they may be
able to afford living closer to work
because they can afford it or having a
more reliable car to get to work becomes
economically within reach which makes
them more reliable workers and helps the
business so it's really important to
think about these changes systemically
rather than myopically this is not to
pretend that the minimum wage can be
increased endlessly but no one is
proposing that this is a very common red
herring on the right where they'll say
listen if $15 an hour is better than 10
why not make the minimum wage $25 an
hour or $100 an hour or $200 an hour
then everybody will just have tons of
money right liberals will hold on a
second
$100 an hour is not an equilibrium wage
hundred dollars an hour is not a wage
that is the logical living wage based on
the cost of living of any particular
place in the United States of America it
is a distraction and it's really
important not to fall for it so my sort
of view on the left discussing minimum
wage increases is number one
don't let them set the talking points
that we have to argue against with
stupid stuff like make the minimum wage
a hundred dollars an hour if you just
want people to make more money that's
stupid that that's not even worth
discussing but let's not be the ones
that pretend that there is not another
side to the ledger
minimum wage increases have effects they
have trickle up effects and they have
trickle-down effects we don't have to
pretend that there's no risk to a
minimum wage increase to be able to
justify it as the right policy in many
cases and in many instances that's the
approach I think that the left should
have and the more informed we are about
studies case studies like the one we see
in New York City the better we will be
able to defend the policies that we want
to see let's take a quick break make
sure to give the David Pakman show a
like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show very quick break and
back with much more right after this